all languages can be summarized in
mathematics and then there's a subset
that is computation
and this is the one that corresponds to
our world is that what you're suggesting
so uh what i would say is that a way out
look
of looking at what mathematics is it's
the domain of all languages and
mathematicians are
starting out with the simplest languages
and exploring them and these are the
formal languages those where you
already know all the properties or you
define them in such a way that you have
a good chance to explore most of the
properties step by step and especially
you can define them in such a way that
you can
make proofs in them
and the reason why we explore
mathematics are
[Music]
by default there's one that we want to
understand uh the things that we only
intuitively understand for instance
geometry right we have an intuitive
understanding of geometry and it's
because our brain makes geometric models
of the
world that we are embedded in
and so we want to have a way to talk
about these models in a way that makes
them explicit and
allows us to debug them and allows us to
express them as formal systems to teach
them to check up on whether our minds
did the geometry right and so on right
and to have all these
uh
models of models these formal
descriptions of geometry that's one
reason why we need mathematics and it's
one of the reasons why
our present mathematical tradition
started
it's uh it started very often as
geometrical descriptions and the
algebraic descriptions that we have
those in terms of formulas and so on are
often a specification for the geometry
and in some sense we teach mathematics
of the wrong way around in school we
teach
kids algebra first as an extension of
counting or generalization of counting
and then you have something like
x
y equals
say
x square
and this is an algebraic description
right and then we learn how to graph
these functions and then we uh notice oh
my god this uh graph of this function
looks a lot like a parabola what a
coincidence and now
we see if we can use this algorithm to
describe a parabola but uh i think that
uh the invention was the other way
around like the world is full of
parabolas whenever you throw stuff you
see a parabola and then you ask yourself
uh what's going on here how can i
systematize that and then you realize
okay i can make a specification that
makes this thing computable because i
can compute the algorithmic description
there's an algorithm for computing uh y
equals x square
right and this allows me to compute the
trajectory of an object that i throw
this is one of the ways that we
discovered mathematics
the other one is that all languages that
we are using so logic
is a
mathematical principle and it's uh in
some sense a subset of the natural
languages that we use but we can extend
it in such a way that it's uh
encompassing
the natural languages in a way
and there was always a big hope that we
could make logic so general that we can
make natural languages so precise that
they become the same thing that these
languages in which we refer to facts
can
express things that we can prove in a
formal strict sense in a way that we can
build machines that can perform
language and that can make statements
that are true or false and so on we look
at the world and we see some patterns
and we try to model those patterns in
mathematics as a great way of modeling
those patterns
is that essentially what you're saying
or is it something else
so mathematics allows us to build
arbitrary languages not just natural
language but it also allows us to build
languages that for instance start out
only with bits
or that starts out with uh bit vectors
and you could say that for instance a
machine learning system
is using a language that as an input as
a bit vector for instance the bit vector
that comes in from a camera sensor and
then it maps this to other bit vectors
and just by finding or order in the
patterns it it's able to gradually make
some sense of these patterns it's able
to relate them and it's for instance
it's able to discover that if you feed
it enough bit vectors all these bit
vectors uh refer to objects in the
three-dimensional space because that's
the best compression that you find over
them it's the best way to make sense of
these patterns to build a model of these
patterns that is most predictive
of their structure and uh mathematics
allows us to
construct and understand the languages
in which that takes place
and uh you uh alluded to another thing
that is uh
the difference between computation and
mathematics
the classical definition of mathematics
that we use in our tradition is mostly
time and stateless it's basically
everything is taking place in a single
state so if you want to
express a temporal sequence in
mathematics you usually use an index
and this index can be discrete or
continuous and you just basically define
something like a loop
only it's not like a loop in a
programming language which goes to this
literally step by step to compute the
sequence you have so instance an
integral operator and this integral
operator states that god makes a loop in
one moment and this loop can integrate
over infinitely many elements because
god can do that right it's an idealized
version of what mathematics can do and
it turns out that there are no gods that
have the power to take infinity media
elements and really integrate them
what we can do is we can take a very
very large number of elements that to us
is almost indistinguishable from
infinitely many elements and then we can
integrate them in a pretty were pretty
long time span of however long it takes
but not over an infinite amount of time
but if we had really infinitely many
elements that you would try to throw
together to integrate to put into
one function and uh execute that
function over these elements this is not
possible in anything that is implemented
in the physical universe and it's also
not possible for anything that is
implemented in mathematics itself
without leading into contradictions
so in some sense what google discovered
i think is that
mathematics this infinities that
actually uses these infinities to
compute things is leading into
contradictions and the thing that
doesn't do that that only uses states
that we can in some sense count up and
actually execute on this is computation
the subset of mathematics that can be
constructed constructive mathematics
and
i would say that constructive
mathematics is not a subset of
mathematics unless you say that
mathematics also encompasses those
things that don't work
right you could say mathematics is all
languages also those languages that are
utter nonsense because they are
contradictory
um that that is one way of looking at it
but the part of mathematics that works
is computation the part of mathematics
that can be implemented and i think for
something to be real
it needs to be implemented
something that is not implementable
something that cannot be realized as a
system that is executable by anything in
mathematics or in physics
is not real
right so constructive mathematics is the
part of mathematics that has a chance of
being real